i did my
undergraduate studies in philosophy also
double majoring in mathematics
at lakeland college now lakeland
university which no longer has a
philosophy program and for all i know
may not have a math program but has
changed quite a bit over the years and i
was one of few philosophy
majors it really was not a big priority
there and it's
you know it was kind of a small school
you might say a bit of a backwater
compared to the wide world of culture
that was going on
at the time and my my two philosophy
professors
were both older you know nearing
retirement age neither one of them
passionately engaged with the field and
both of them the consensus that they had
was that there were there are basically
three main things going on in philosophy
in in the united states and in europe
and that was
analytic philosophy which they thought
was you know kind of interesting but
probably going to die out process
philosophy
so you know that was sort of
representing the american
side of things and then existentialism
and then they said well there's also
marxism but i don't know that anyone
really takes that
so seriously and so you know you can
guess that
we weren't getting a very wide range of
contemporary thinkers
and you know as most places there was an
intro class
and a logic class and an ethics class
and then you had
you know things like philosophy of
religion which i didn't take because i
wasn't interested in religion at all at
the time
but you had some other philosophies of
this and that
and then there was the sequence of
history of philosophy and the way that
they did it there was ancient and
medieval
basically just ancient with you know a
little bit of augustine and aquinas
tacked on at the end
modern philosophy and then contemporary
philosophy and contemporary philosophy
consisted largely of
some you know existentialist stuff some
uh
early analytic stuff william james to
throw in for pragmatism and some process
philosophy stuff and you know you'd get
some other philosophy stuff in some of
your other
classes as well and it was in a modern
philosophy class that i actually got
introduced to
a much wider range of continental
philosophy and it wasn't through the
teacher
it was through the quirk of there being
a
student in the class yoshihiro manoa
who i became kind of friends with after
a while he was a hard person to be
friends with but you know
there's a whole other story probably to
be told there
and yoshihiro was from japan his family
had made it big
in the real estate business in tokyo so
they had plenty of money i got the idea
he was kind of a black sheep of his
family
and they'd allowed him to like go where
he wanted to go for some reason he
wanted to be at lakeland college
in you know just outside of sheboygan
wisconsin
and study philosophy there who knows why
you know and he was always kind of a
sour guy but that was i think in part
because
he wasn't all that happy about about
life and he was also kind of a deep
thinker
it just took a lot to bring that out of
him and so in our modern philosophy
class there were four of us in the class
i don't really remember the other
students that well but
yoshihira and i would would talk about
stuff he was a little bit shy
but he was friends with a friend of mine
and they would hang out together
a lot of the foreign students all hung
out together and i hung out with them
so it was about maybe i would say
two-thirds of the way through the
semester and we all had to write like a
final paper and present it to the class
you know sort of typical
undergraduate stuff something easy for
the professor to assign and to grade not
a lot of work for him
we could do what the what work we wanted
to do i don't even know what i wrote on
at that point probably
something having to do with with
descartes and spinoza
but he ended up writing this paper
and it was around 70 pages long and
then he came to me and he said i need
you to present this paper
because i don't feel that my english is
good enough
to present it it was good enough to
write it but not to present it i was
like oh okay that sounds fine
and then he handed me a stack of books
i don't actually have all the books that
he gave me i'm missing one
in here but this these are the books
that yoshihira
gave me and that helped to fill in
a lot of gaps i mean i filled in some
other gaps on my own
by reading stuff that i bought and used
bookstores and every one of these was
at the time that it was actually this
isn't the original copy of
anti-oedipus it was a different edition
that we had i think we we had duplicates
so we got rid of the one that yoshihiro
gave me
but they were all brand new when he gave
them to me
um so that was kind of nice as well and
he was like he's he laid down this stack
of books and he's like in order to
understand
my paper you're going to have to read
these
and i was like oh okay
that sounds good i mean i was you know i
had a lot more time on my hands then
that i did now
and he said you can keep them these are
for you
and i was like free books sounds sounds
awesome right
so uh as it turned out you know you
didn't actually
need to read all of these in order to
understand his paper which
the main point of which was that modern
philosophy is monological
and previous philosophy had been
dialogical and we should make philosophy
dialogical again in the present it was
the same point made over and over and
over again
but what was the cool thing about it is
i i got all these books out of it so i'm
going to tell you a little bit about
these books and why it was nice
for for him to you know give them to me
essentially gift them to me
so how should i organize them let's
actually start with uh horkheimer and
adornor
adorn all the dialectic of enlightenment
this uh was was a nice um
sort of addition actually this is this
is this is not the original
edition either as far as i remember now
too
um but you know it was kind of a cool
thing to read this is this is sort of a
classic of critical theory
if you want to understand it you need to
go through that
then um there was the deluge
and guitare anti-oedipus capitalism and
schizophrenia
now this is weird wild wacky stuff
particularly
if you don't have as much of a
background as
you you probably need to to make sense
of it so
i got thrown into the deep end when it
comes to duluz
and gatari and you know i'd read it and
i was like wow this is you know i know
enough about freud to have some idea
what he's talking about
but some of this other stuff i i don't
know at all
and so you know i kept plugging away at
it read other things i'm not actually a
big fan
of delusion guitar together i actually
like to lose his stuff on his own
quite a bit better and then uh
there is the one baudrillard book uh
sim uh simulations uh which was was kind
of nice to have
um these these little tiny tiny books uh
semi-text
right and it gave me enough of what
baudrillard
was talking about you know i was into
philosophy of language
so all this talk about signs and hyper
reality that was that was really cool to
get into
and then of course a big head cracker
foucault's the order of things
maybe not the place that you should
begin with foucault
but this is the first [ __ ] book that i
had
and you know it was it was kind of nice
to to have it and to read through it i
can't say
that i actually understood that much of
what i was reading
as an undergraduate i i had a foucault
class in graduate school and reread it
then
and by then had enough under my belt to
actually understand what was being
talked about
and to recognize that despite foucault's
insistence that he was not a
structuralist
in this book he actually was a
structuralist then we had roland bart
and there were there were two things
that he gave me from bart we have this
this
you know pretty cool elements of
semiology pretty straightforward book
again in the philosophy of language or
linguistics
and i thought it was you know this is
some really cool stuff here
and then there was empire signs which i
didn't really know what to make of
then we got to something and i'm you
know i don't know why
um yoshihiro was so into bakting
but i'm so glad that he was because
he gave me these marxism and the
philosophy of language
which is by voloshinov which most people
most scholars think is actually
a pseudonym for mikhail bakhtin
and this was you know again some really
mind-blowing stuff you put it side by
side
with some of the philosophy of language
stuff that i was getting through
analytic philosophy which
largely got itself you know into
vitkenstinian
confusions and then managed to extricate
itself
from that and then some of the stuff
that i was i was looking at in in other
areas with
like the foundations of logic because of
my philosophy mathematics background
and this that was focusing on you know
how
how
marxist substructures superstructures
fit in with each other the differences
between
different kinds of utterances this was
really interesting stuff for me
and then he gave me these two
things rob lay in his world and
problems of dostoevsky's poetics
and i you know i can say that i never
have read the entirety of roblay and his
world it's it's a book that i've read
around in
and read some significant parts of and
you know it's
baktin is some pretty intense
heady stuff this one i loved
this this book i've read over and over
again
problems of dostoevsky's poetics and
it is such an interesting work
all the different things that are going
on in this well there's a lot of there's
a lot of um
like water stains and coffee stains in
this book
as well let's show you you know that i
was kind of i'm
pretty rough on my books and
you know what's going on here in terms
of
the analysis that's taking place in
terms of
language and ethics and the narrative
itself is was pretty
amazing so you know over the years i've
really benefited from yoshihiro's
um whatever was going on in his head
some sort of generosity some sort of
project that he had me in on
and this this stack of books wound up
filling in a lot of the curriculum
that we just didn't have where i went to
undergrad so by the time that i got to
grad school
you know i took a gap year as they call
it these days
i looked at it as just i was burnt out
and just wanted to work a job and work
out my languages and save to go to
europe
which i did between 94 and 95 i went in
the summer of 95 and then immediately
started grad school
in 95 at southern illinois university a
pluralistic department where
we had representatives of continental
philosophy analytic philosophy classical
american philosophy
we had one asian guy who actually got
got fired for reasons we can talk about
some other time and then we had a few
people doing history of philosophy as
well
but also good good other departments i
worked with the classics department the
history department the english
department
speech com department to take other
classes you know
i i came in and if i hadn't had some
background in this i
i probably would have been much more
lost than than i was because i
this enabled me to have some idea of
what the
not just the cutting edge but the
current discussions
actually were otherwise i would have
thought that you know
sarts was pretty much the end of the
story maybe with
deboir added i remember one of the
things i had read was was uh
marcusa and i was asking people if they
were you know if they were interested in
marcus and they looked at me like i was
some weird oddball
when i got to siu but you know there was
some interest in marxism but this
post-structuralist stuff
was was really big um not just in the
philosophy department but also the
speech com department in the english
department
and so you know there's there's a lot of
things
in the world of philosophy that are
rather contingent
and what we study what we get introduced
to
is so contingent on who we encounter
and what they put in front of us so i
was so
fortunate that i had somebody
not my professors but somebody else who
could toss these books in my lap
and give me some other things to read
and work on
and fill in some of the gaps in my
understanding of
what you know what was interesting and
worth
studying at the time so i should say a
belated thanks to yoshihiro manoa
you know some of these books i've
returned to over and over again
in the course of my career and my
intellectual life
um we're talking about something that
that happened
you know decades ago and still has some
impact on me and on the videos that i i
shoot for
all of you someday down the line if i
had to pick one of these that i'd like
to get to
the first someday maybe i'll actually
shoot some stuff on problems of
dostoevsky's
poetics and on bhaktine himself i know
people would probably rather see uh
anti-oedipus and dialectic of
enlightenment and the order of things
but
you know you got to go where your heart
is i think and i
resonate more with bach team than i do
with these other
authors so you know we'll see what
happens in the future with these
interesting books that i was gifted
you